breaking news a new covid variant just
dropped right in time to keep all you
sheep in your stalls for another few
months
the new omicron variant has actually hit
the market ahead of schedule but it
seems the delta variant did not have
enough of you cowering for your lives
and blindly following big daddy fouchy
so we needed a new one now we're headed
for a few more months of masks and
lockdowns getting a few more jabs and
boosters and giving away a little bit
more of our freedom and rights and way
of life to the liberal ruling class at
which point the pandemic still will not
be over but at which point people might
begin to realize what some of us have
known all along
there's always going to be another
variant i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from last wednesday oh my gosh
before thanksgiving was from frank s who
says democrat 2022 midterm slogan
lower your expectations bigot yeah
that's
absolutely true now
a lot of people have a lot of big
expectations heading into the christmas
season
which is why if you want to raise your
expectations but lower the amount that
you can expect to pay i would strongly
recommend you check out pearlsource
there is nothing more classic and
timeless than fine pearl jewelry as a
matter of fact you know what i got sweet
little lisa for christmas last year
pearl jewelry that's exactly what i did
and at the pearl source you will get the
highest quality pearl jewelry at up to
70 percent off retail prices they cut
out the middleman by eliminating those
crazy jewelry store markups and sell
directly to you the consumer at the
pearl source you will find the largest
selection of pearls available anywhere
and each jewelry piece is custom made
specifically for you now is the time to
start shopping for the holiday season do
not wait the pearlsource offers fast and
free two-day shipping on every order
with zero contact delivery everything
comes beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box so it is ready to be given
as a gift
i love it i love the way pearls look i
think they make a really elegant
wonderful
gift for a limited time listeners to my
show can take
20 off your entire order do not wait
until it's too late to do your holiday
shopping go to thepearlsource.com
knowlescannonwles enter promo code
knowles at checkout for 20 off your
entire order if you want fine pearl
jewelry at the best prices online go
straight to the source the pearl source
that is thepearlsource.com
knowles canon wles enter promo code
knowles kwles at checkout another great
thing that you're going to want to get
for for the christmas season and you're
going to want to get it today because
today is the last day is a subscription
to the daily wire last year i mentioned
this in a little video over the weekend
but last year was the best year ever for
daily wire one of the best years ever
period i would say uh amid all the
difficulty and the struggle and all the
libs trying to shut us down
we
we got to fight back and we got to fight
back because of you because of your
memberships we got to uncancel actors
who the libs tried to cancel like gina
carano disney tries to cancel gina
carano we say we love gina carano we're
gonna make a movie with her we can do
that because of your money
that's why because you are joining the
fight with us you are literally joining
in becoming members we can we can do
that we can push back in that culture we
can engage in investigative journalism
probably flipped a governorship in
virginia
the the libs have all the investigative
journalists just about
the right is usually reacting to liberal
outlets like the new york times and the
washington post well what happens when
we do our own work what happens when we
uncover our own stories
it exposes a lot of corruption on the
left sometimes it can flip a seat
we have been uh obviously getting a lot
more into entertainment we got this new
show coming out or just came out i guess
with with adam carolla we are fighting
the biden administration we're the lead
plaintiffs in this case pushing back
against the mandatory fouchyauchi and
and making a lot of headway we can only
do that because of you today
is the last day to get our best sale
ever to my knowledge 50 off the
membership that's with code dw
50 dailywire.com subscribe code
dw50 you're going to want to subscribe
now
before
the omicron
shuts down the word the omicron is upon
us you've all got to hide and cower in
fear why is the variant called the
omicron variant
it's a greek letter
so
the only ones that i remember were the
og covid
and then there was the delta and then
now there's the omicron but it turns out
there have been a number of other
variants too they just haven't been as
popular you know they haven't made the
billboard top top 100 so
there were all these different variants
that the next variant that was supposed
to be up was the
new variant
nu
followed by the
zai variant x i but the world health
organization skipped over those two
variants
and then they moved right on to
the omicron why is that
well the zai variant is spelled just
like the name of the leader of china and
they don't want to to point out that
it's china's fault that we have the
virus in the first place
so and the world health organization has
admitted this by the way this is not
some you know
ridiculous conspiracy theory or
something like that they're actually
coming out and saying no because new
sounds a little bit like new and z zai
rather that's a very common last name
also happens to be the last name of the
leader of china so you know we're just
going to skip that because of xenophobia
or whatever we're going to move right on
to omicron so a lot of conservatives
right now are saying hey this is bs we
got to call it the zai varian the g
variant we've got to point out that it's
all china's fault yes it is it is all
china's fault but i actually think this
is a
bad path to go down for conservatives
i i actually think this kind of blind
jingoism
is not smart for conservatives because
yes while it's all china's fault and the
liberal establishment is covering that
up
it's also fauci's fault okay it's also
the fault of of the
global
technocratic public health elite okay dr
fauci and the nih were funding the
research in china
that
led to the the breakout of this virus
all right
they were funding gain of function
research in wuhan and then dr fauci
perjured himself about that and then
documents revealed that they actually
were funding that and they're still
denying that it had anything to do with
the with the virus and the origins of
the virus are murky but every day they
seem to get a little bit clearer okay
so yes we can all make fun yes this is
china's fault yes it's xi jinping's
fault uh let's call it the g variant
yeah what let's call it the fauci
variant huh let's call it the global
technocratic public health elite variant
let's call it the forget about the
variance at all and focus on the actual
problem which is the lockdowns and the
people taking away our freedoms and our
rights and our way of life because
there's always going to be this virus
the virus isn't going away okay there's
always going to be another variant and
so if you put all of your attention on
the virus itself
then you're never going to get back to
your normal way of life because the
virus is never going away just like the
flu has never gone away the this virus
the wu flu is never going away
okay focus on the lockdowns and who's
pushing the lockdowns it's not xi
jinping
it is
unfortunately bad actors much closer to
home
speaking of dr fauci
our friend senator cruz just suggested
that dr fauci be prosecuted there are a
number of reasons for which dr fauci
should be prosecuted one of which is he
perjured himself right he was talking to
rand paul rand paul said dr fauci do you
do you support did you ever fund going
to function research in china and dr
factory said senator paul we have never
ever once
funded any single penny of gain of
function research and if we did it was
totally fine and right so he hedged his
bets he spoke out of two sides of his
mouth he gave contradictory answers in
the same breath and then it turned out
no actually they did fund gain of
function research rand paul had him dead
to rights
so senator cruz senator cruz says
that dr fauci maybe should be prosecuted
well dr fauci just punched back and said
i should be bra i should be prosecuted
senator
cruz told the attorney general you
should be prosecuted yeah
i'd have to laugh at that
i should be prosecuted
what happened on january 6 senator
what happened on january 6. do you see
what he's
saying here
the
clear suggestion
is that because
ted cruz
raised objections to the way that the
electoral votes were being counted and
suggested a pause to create an electoral
commission like we have done before in
american history because of the many
irregularities and rule changes and
outright illegal practices in the 2020
election
because a
sitting elected united states senator
proposed
a
a
procedure
for the on the floor of the united
states senate that he should be
prosecuted for that do you realize how
backwards that is do you realize how
deeply
anti-constitutional and anti-american
that is
this
unelected
twerp
dr fauci
this guy who has now gone through seven
united states presidents highest paid
employee of the federal government
who has perjured himself in my view
who has
helped to
not just lock down americans for 18
months but actually encouraged and
funded the kind of research that led to
this pandemic in the first place
dr fauci is saying that if an elected
united states senator
debates a political issue on the floor
of the senate he should go to jail
that is some scary stuff you know
the left and the right get a little
hyperbolic sometimes when we talk about
tyranny and the subversion of democracy
and you know everyone everyone does this
what dr fauci is doing here is about as
clear an example of that as is possible
he is a totally unaccountable totally
unelected bureaucrat
who is suggesting that we prosecute and
what jail
a u.s senator
for for
proposing an election procedure that
that we've already done in american
history it's not even an unprecedented
election procedure
for for suggesting a political measure
on the floor of the united states senate
sick stuff six this guy might be the
single most power hungry power mad jerk
in the united states speaking of
congress
got to get to lauren bober
lauren bobert
is a firebrand conservative member of
congress
uh i think freshman member of congress
and uh lauren
was at a fundraiser of some sort and she
made a joke
about ilhan omar being a terrorist
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol we're going back to my office
and we get an elevator and i see a
capitol police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see fret all over his
face and he's reaching and i'm like
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it like what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
on omar
and i said well she doesn't have a
backpack we should be fine
so we only had one floor to go and he
was like uh do i say it why not i looked
over and i said oh look the jihad squad
decided to show up for work today
that is not funny lauren that is not i
bet no one laughed
no one left hearing that joke right not
except every single one of you left
right you've all at least you chuckled
but you're not allowed to do that's
wrong
ilhano what
just because
she has openly
giggled over acts of major acts of
terrorism and terror groups ilhan omar
just because of that you think that you
can
suggest that she herself is a terror
that's awful the left would never do
that the left would never call
conservatives terrorists or
insurrectionists or white supremacists
or neo-nazis or oh they do all of that
all the time right and they face no
consequences for it whatsoever but
lauren
lauren made a joke and that you're not
allowed to do that you're not allowed to
joke if you're a conservative ah and of
course
the squishes
they had they got nature they got their
nice pearls on and they just clutched
them the minute lauren made her joke
they just clutched them as hard as they
possibly could and that can put a lot of
strain on your muscles and on your back
which is why you should check out x
chair how about a gift that keeps on
giving you joy and comfort every day all
year long all throughout the day a gift
that looks as good as it feels and a
gift that will actually pay for itself
in terms of how much more productive you
will be at work i am talking about
giving yourself the gift of an ex chair
i love my x chair it is by far the most
advanced shocking ergonomic chair i have
ever used and it is probably the coolest
looking piece of furniture around this
joint not only is extra the world's
greatest office chair but with its
patented lmx technology it doubles i'm
not joking as a massage chair and can
either cool or warm your back yes you
can get a massage at the office without
worrying about hr coming and knocking on
your door here is x chair's holiday gift
to you save 100
off your ex chair just by purchasing it
at
xchairknowles.com right now that is the
letter x
chair
knowles
k-w-l-e-s
dot com x-chair has a 30-day guarantee
of complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as thirty dollars
a month go to
exchairknolls.com and save what's that
url x chair knowles.com so lauren bobert
freshman republican member of congress
makes this joke and says she saw a cop
running at her she sees a silhouette
next to her she said don't worry she
doesn't have a backpack on ha ha ha oh
oh no you can't that you can't make that
joke so ilhan omar
seized upon this non-traversing and
tweeted out quote
saying i am a suicide bomber is no
laughing matter
then she tagged the gop leader and nancy
pelosi and she said
these people need to take appropriate
action normalizing this bigotry not only
endangers my life but the lives of all
muslims anti-muslim bigotry has no place
in congress
okay so the claim here the premise of
ilhan omar saying that we got to boot
out lauren bobert is
saying i'm a suicide bomber is no
laughing matter which uh reminded me of
that time
that uh ilhan omar was caught on video
literally laughing over suicide bombers
i remember um when i was in college i
took a terrorism class and is that a
such thing yeah there was so you go out
there is a lab for that there was a
there was a class that you said did you
go to lobby no or
and so it was it was the the thing that
was interesting in the class was every
time the the the professor said okay
that he sort of like his shoulders went
up and you know he's in command al-qaeda
you know
experts
it's just al-qaeda
you know the suicide bombers that i'm
laughing over but but lauren bobert
can't do that she can't let she can't
that's not funny
that's not
funny so it's total bs ilhano mark can
go pound sand
the the left
does what lauren bobert did to us
10 times 100 times over with a lot more
institutional power i just don't want to
hear it i don't want to hear it from the
libs and i don't want to hear it from
the squishes and i definitely don't want
to hear it from ilhan omar who literally
laughs about suicide bombers and
unfortunately
lauren bobert apologized
here is her apology quote i apologize to
anyone in the muslim community i
offended with my comment about
representative omar i've reached out to
her office to speak with her directly
there are plenty of policy differences
to focus on without this unnecessary
distraction
why would
why would lauren apologize to the muslim
community she didn't make a joke about
muslims she made a joke about ilhan omar
not all muslims giggle about al-qaeda
and hezbollah
not all muslims
do the kinds of things that ilhan omar
does
she made a joke about ilhan omar not
about all muslims so if she wants to
apologize i guess you could apologize to
ilhan omar but i don't think she should
ilhan omar is not playing in good faith
here
ilhan omar does the same sort of thing
to us all the time 10 times over
and ilhan omar deserves the criticism
ilhan omar has has really done some
questionable things
i
really like lauren bobert i like her
personally a lot
i think she's learning a hard lesson
here
which is
you got to be ready when the when the
cancel mob comes
okay and in this case it it can be very
tempting to apologize to the mob and i
have no doubt that lauren did this in
good faith and maybe she just thought
that her joke went too far and it really
did offend this whole community of
people it didn't i don't think ilhan
omar speaks for all muslims or anything
like that okay and unfortunately that
what what the political consequence of
this will be
is that
lauren bobert told the joke i don't
think she lost a single supporter for
telling the joke
and then
she apologized probably because kevin
mccarthy made her apologize i'm not
accusing him of that but someone in gop
leadership made her apologize and she
did it and then she lost supporters
i bet there are going to be a lot of
people now who once supported lauren
bobert who are going to be less likely
to support her because she apologized
and it's a lot of people virtually
everyone's going to do this especially
when you got gop leadership on the phone
yelling at you saying they're going to
take away everything you've ever worked
for in your life
if you don't apologize but one i guess
that's an argument for better gop
leadership
with this democratic party with this
ilhan omar there is absolutely no reason
to issue some kind of public apology
over this speaking of religious conflict
is a terrible terrible story
from the telegraph this is an exclusive
story
that notre dame the cathedral of notre
dame one of the greatest works in the
history of the west
notre dame you remember burned
a couple years ago
now they're going to re rebuild parts of
the roof and the interior
and they're going to turn it into a woke
disneyland revamp according to this
headline
the world famous cathedral will be
turned according to this report into a
quote experimental showroom
under the proposed changes confessional
boxes altars and classical sculptures
will be replaced with modern art murals
and new sound and light effects to
create
emotional spaces
there will be themed chapels on a
discovery trail with an emphasis on
africa and asia while quotes from the
bible will be projected under chapel
walls in various languages
including mandarin and the final chapel
on the trail will have a strong
environmental emphasis
so what's going to happen
according to the proposed changes is
that the cathedral of notre dame
an
icon filled with icons but an icon
itself of christianity
will be claimed by secular liberalism
and turned into a cathedral secular
liberalism
and we're you know listening to lauren
bobert's joke about ilhan omar and
conflict between christianity and islam
at least when the muslims steal one of
our great cathedrals
they usually don't completely destroy it
so i think of the hagia sophia in
constantinople one of if not the
greatest cathedral ever built and the
muslims stole it and they turned it into
a mosque and they damaged it to a
considerable degree but they didn't
totally destroy it okay and they just
covered up some icons and they put their
own stuff up there
but they did not
destroy it nearly as much as the secular
liberal
left is trying to do to notre dame
the muslims are positively respectful
compared to the secular
leftists here in the west
this would be a great tragedy if they
are allowed to get away with this so how
could they be allowed to get away can't
the catholic church step in no because
the secular liberals stole notre dame
from the catholic church centuries ago
notre dame is property of the french
state
and so
because catholicism has not been the
religion of france in hundreds of years
because now liberalism is with all of
its very various
uh uh
aspects multiculturalism
environmentalism and all the rest of it
because that's the new state religion
the cathedral the great pinnacle of
french art is going to be turned into a
cathedral for liberalism unless we stop
it i think there's a chance that we can
stop it
but
there is going to have to be a large
public outcry and
conservatives in france are going to
have to gain some political power in
order to do it
the secular left
needs to transform everything there's a
new ad for the norwegian postal service
that
i'm not sure
really how it was promoting the postal
service
all i know is that it turned santa
gay
so you see a guy
he's waiting in his nice christmasy
living room
oh here we go some packages from the
postal service i guess merry christmas
he walks back into the living room
there's santa
so i can be with you says santa
and then there's this guy and he's
looking at santa in a kind of strange
way
[Music]
walks up to santa
and uh
are they gonna wait a second are they
no
not santa claus no not you don't need to
do this to santa claus to end
they okay and they kiss santa kisses
that okay this
i think
we don't need to see santa make again i
saw daddy kissing santa which we don't
we don't need to watch that zooms out
and
now you've gotta frequent the norwegian
postal service
a lot of people are looking at this ad
and saying hey man you know i'm not i'm
no homophobe but uh
we don't need to make everything gay do
we blake masters who's running for the
senate from arizona he said this about
superman they're turning superman gay
now he said you know not everything has
to be gay but the thing is
it does actually everything does have to
be gay
this is the way it gets right back to
the notre dame point it gets right back
to this religious conflict okay
there is going to be
a sexual standard every society is going
to have one and they're going to say
some
this is not true just of sex it's true
of everything they're gonna say some
things are good to do and some things
are bad to do some behavior is good some
behavior is bad some speech is good some
some speech is bad and
and that's especially true when it comes
to sex because sex is so important to
our human nature and so if the left is
going to totally transform our sexual
ethic then everything needs to follow
the new rules
now you might remember back to the old
times when this was not true well how
are you going to preserve those memories
the way you're going to do it is with
legacy box christmas christmas time is
near time for toys and time for cheer
you've got all these wonderful memories
of christmases thanksgivings all the
wonderful memories and they're sitting
in a box you're sitting in a box
somewhere degrading either they're at
risk of fire or flood or just old father
time which degrades your pictures your
cassettes your old movies legacy box
will help you preserve them the way it
works you send in all your old media the
pictures and the movies and all of it
you send it in to legacy box they will
hand digitize everything
they will then put it on a thumb drive
or the cloud or a dvd or some
combination thereof and then you will
have those memories forever and old
father time ain't going to stop them and
the floods and the fires ain't going to
stop them either these are irreplaceable
sentimental memories do not be like me i
actually lost some pictures and i
thought they were gone forever
fortunately i found some more
immediately sent them into legacy box
legacy box is giving our listeners the
best deal of the year right now for
their black friday event go to
legacybox.com
knowlescanwles to save 65
with limited quantities ready to ship
this deal will go fast that's
legacybox.com
knowles you will get a whopping 65 off
legacybox.com
knowles if you're a fan of my colleague
matt walsh you're going to want to hear
this the daily wire host and former
virginia resident trans virginia
resident has just written his first
children's book
i've read it more than once and i can
tell you it is a very important piece of
literature that you're going to want on
your kids shelf matt will be launching
his book tonight on tucker carlson's
show you're not going to want to miss it
tune in fox news 8 pm eastern 7 pm
central for a very special announcement
from our very own matt walsh also as i
may have mentioned at the top of the
show
today is the last day
to get 50 off your daily wire membership
if you have not
yet become a daily wire member you're
missing out on all the great stuff like
all access with me ben drew matt walsh
you're missing out on the candace owens
show more than that you're helping us
more than that if you are not a member
then you are not helping us build
something important you know which is
what we're working on doing a way to
stand up to the left so join right now
50 off with code dw50 at dailywire.com
subscribe you won't regret it also i
know you're all buying your christmas
presents and your stocking stuffers and
all that i would strongly recommend
two number one selling books one was the
number one book on amazon for a week and
a half it continues to sell like
hotcakes it is the gift of knowledge
that you can give all your democrat
friends and relatives it is called
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide which president
donald trump hailed as a great book for
your reading enjoyment
the other one is my number one national
bestselling book from this year
it's called speechless controlling words
controlling minds
thank you to everyone who's bought it
already would be a great gift to give to
your friends and relatives this year
they're both on sale right now
at the daily wire shop at regnary at
anywhere you buy your books on amazon i
think it's like 30 or 31 off right now
so go get it we'll be right back with a
lot more
welcome back to the show
the norwegians turned
santa
gay and they they sort of have to
they they they have to superman has to
go gay and that
the the i think the the libertarian idea
is look
we don't really need any rules you just
you do you i'll do me you don't you
don't push your views on me and i won't
push my views on you and we'll all just
get along but that's not how society
works society has views and so
if
if we live in a society that like our
traditional society which said that sex
has a purpose to quote the great
philosopher nor macdonald sex is a
filthy
shameful thing that's obviously only
meant for procreation if if we live in a
world that views
sex as having a purpose then that is
what sex is going to be geared toward
okay and there are going to be
unusual kind of desires and activities
outside of that and those activities and
desires will probably be tolerated but
they won't they won't be celebrated and
they won't they that won't be seen as
the end of sex and marriage will be
encouraged and families will be
encouraged and that was the way our
civilization worked for at least a
thousand years more than that more than
a thousand years
now since
certainly since the 1960s the purpose of
sex has not been
understood to be procreation it's not
the human person is not seen to have a
definite end you know a tea loss a
purpose of of our lives it it's it has
been thought that
the point is just to get pleasure just
to kind of feel good if it feels good do
it and so in that world
that's that's the kind of standard
that's going to be encouraged and so for
i mean we're kind of joking about gay
santa here but that is going to be the
case
for everything and you're going to have
to make a decision are you going to give
in
to that zeitgeist are you going to give
in to the spirit of the age and just let
secularism and leftism roll over your
whole culture or are you going to stand
up and say no actually you shouldn't do
certain things you shouldn't behave in
certain ways you shouldn't you shouldn't
be taught certain things
we're going we're going to set the
standards ourselves that's what dave
chappelle is doing right now so dave
chappelle
i graduated from duke ellington high
school
and duke ellington high school is what
he credits with spurring his interest in
the arts and creativity
and so this high school
was planning on naming its new theater
after chappelle
but then dave chappelle did that
vaguely not totally woke comedy special
recently on netflix and now there are
protests not to name the school after
him
so
here's dave chappelle's response he said
quote
naming the theater after him is quote
the most significant honor of my life
and he proposed a
contest
he said the people who don't want it
named after me can raise some money for
the school i'm going to raise some money
for this school and the people who do
want it named after me or who are
neutral and whichever one raises more
money their way goes
it says whichever opinion donates the
highest collective dollar amount wins if
by april those against the chappelle
theater exceed the donations of those
who are neutral or in favor of the
theater being named chappelle i will
gladly step aside if not i will happily
attend the naming ceremony and if you
don't care enough to donate please shut
the f up forever dave
and this is a great way to do it because
no matter which
side wins the school is going to get
more donations so i think it's a classy
way to do it
but this is also the way to engage in
the culture
i think the squish
attitude which has been the attitude of
many people on the right
for a couple of decades has been
you know let them have it they want it
let them have it they don't you don't
want the school named after me okay fine
i don't that's i don't need your school
named after me or your theater named
after me okay hey you want you want you
want to do your own thing you do your
own thing i'll do my own thing it's fine
who cares you do you
that's not what dave's doing dave is
saying no you are going to
sit in my theater the dave chappelle
theater i'm not going to let you have it
i'm not going to let you do whatever you
want i'm not going to let you have your
own way i am going to force my will upon
you
because my will happens to be more in
accord with logic and reason and things
that are good and your awful
cancel culture woke left just use
whatever term you want
your desires are bad and so i'm going to
stop your desires i'm going to push my
desires and deal with it deal with it
buddy that's the right attitude that's
the attitude that the right needs to
have
cert there is no way to have a society
in which
we don't hold certain beliefs about what
is good or what is freedom or what is
equality or what is what we should be
pursuing right some view is always going
to predominate
so it's either going to be ours or it's
going to be the other guys do you want
it to be the other guys do you want it
to be the crazy radical left that wants
to destroy everything you cherish
or not the cathedral of notre dame it's
either going to be a christian cathedral
or it's going to be a secular liberal
cathedral or it's going to be a mosque
or but it's going to be something it
can't be nothing there's no neutrality
all right you've got to pick and i love
that dave is saying no you don't get my
theater you don't get my theater buster
and i don't think that we should allow
the left to have our communities or our
states
or our families or our nation
look at what ron desantis is doing right
now in florida
the
left has been trying to undermine our
way of life especially getting back to
the omicron and the forever lockdown you
know the worst part of the 15 days to
slow the spread is the first 18 months
they say
they've they've been trying to run
roughshod over our way of life and a lot
of conservatives have kind of rolled
over
and they said well the experts say so
and if and even the ones who don't go
along with the experts they'll go along
with the corporations say well but the
free market says that a handful of woke
multinational corporations get to do
whatever they want no matter what my way
of life or preferences or political
tradition so what ron desantis has done
is he said no oh disney you want to have
a vaccine mandate in disney world in
florida no you can't we're not going to
let you do that we're going to wield the
power of the state
which i am now currently embodying iran
desantis because the people of florida
elected me i am going to channel their
political will and i'm going to say no
and i'm going to use my judgment because
that's why they put me into office and
i'm going to say no you stupid what
corporation you don't get to do that
uh-uh
tough luck but but it's our right under
the free market of the and the we can
companies can do no you can't do
whatever you want because i'm the
governor and i say you can't
so what are you going to do about it
and you know what they're going to do
they're going to back down that's what
they just did
disney has paused it's covered 19
vaccine mandate for workers
at the walt disney world theme park
that's the one in florida
they sent a memo about the pause just a
few days ago
attributing the state legislature's
passing of limits on employer powers
regarding the vaccinations as its
primary cause the white house is furious
about this
gensake was asked about it and she said
well desantis is taking step backwards
and he's not governing the way he should
on the virus rhonda santos has the best
record of any governor in the country on
coronavirus
remember while they were pillaring ron
desantis they were exalting
andrew cuomo in new york and then what
happened it turned out cuomo was killing
senior citizens and getting up to some
other activities and ron desantis record
was
stellar on the virus and now the white
house is crying they're like that meme
of the guy with the tears where they're
saying no you can't
wield the power of the state to stop our
corporations uh yes we can sorry
yes we can and that's exactly what we're
going to do
that's the only way that is the only way
that we are ever going to stop the
steady march of leftism
conservatives would not have such a hard
time winning
if they would just get out of their own
way
okay here's a story out of new york very
sad story
new york city man
was out on bail
for possession of an illegal firearm
he was on parole for a prior gun crime
conviction
and you know what he did over the past
few days
he walked up to a random 13 year old boy
and shot him in the neck this is a guy
who should not have been out of jail
he should not have been out of jail on
bail for the most recent he actually
shouldn't have been out of jail even to
be able to go back into jail to get out
of jail because he should have still
been in jail from the past
conviction
and the guy was out of jail and so he
shoots a 13 year old boy in the neck
here's the
new york city police officer describing
what happened
now the individual that was taken into
custody
it's got to be noted here
this is an individual
who today
is on parole for a firearms and illegal
drug convention from back in 2010
this individual
for role 8
while on parole
on that charge in 2019 he gets indicted
on that gun
and he bails out so this individual
today is on the street while on parole
while for a firearm while out on bail on
another firearm and today he's walking
around the bronx with the firearm we
have a 13 year old boy
shot in the neck and for the grace of
god he's alive here today
if republicans want to win elections
they can just run on that okay here's
here's the big i'm i'm not exactly
matter nick okay i don't consider myself
the greatest political philosopher of
all time but maybe i maybe relative to
the knuckleheads running the show today
maybe i am
because
what i would run on if i were advising a
political campaign is
put the bad guys in prison
there are bad guys out there who are
shooting your kids through the neck and
we're going to arrest them and keep them
in prison for a very long time
you know the republicans always talk
about how they have trouble winning over
the women vote the suburban women voters
you know what suburban women love when
bad guys aren't shooting their kids
through the neck
you know what suburban women love law
and order and safety
so why don't republicans are republicans
running on that no they're not you know
what they're running on criminal justice
reform like a bunch of dummies
criminal justice reform which is a
euphemism for letting criminals out of
prison why would we do that crime is
spiking it's going through the roof
and they're talking about
over-incarceration
when crime is going through the roof
that means you have under-incarceration
you don't have enough criminals in jail
why are we doing this it is because
of the squishes and the libertarians i'm
sorry to say i like my libertarian
friends very much
but that is the faction of the right
that is pushing
letting criminals out of prison or
reducing sentences or legalizing certain
drugs or legalizing certain offenses
that's the the weak on crime
portion of the right
has a disproportionate influence
and it has been electorally a disaster
for us
and so what we need that that group the
the hyper-libertarian group that wants
to legalize everything and let all the
criminals out of prison
they have no constituency nobody votes
for that if you if you look at the
political compass quiz of you know are
you in the bottom left or the top right
or whatever nobody is in that quadrant
certainly the republican base is not in
that quadrant certainly the suburban
mothers are not in that quadrant
run on getting tough i can't but you
know even trump who is a really tough
guy he did a great job in many ways
even he pushed the jail break bill
that's the kind of currency that this
has in the leadership of the republican
party and that is how divorced the
leadership of the republican party is
from the actual republican base and
forget just the republicans from from
actually
just the regular old american people
these republicans cannot win for losing
they can't help but clutch defeat from
the jaws of victory speaking of crime
there is new information out from the
legacy establishment media
on the cause of that horrific crime that
took place in waukesha wisconsin you
remember
the scenes dozens and dozens of people
injured six people killed
including a little boy
lots of senior citizen women injured
and killed for that matter
so the washington post
has a tweet out about this about this
attack
quote
here's what we know so far on the
sequence of events that led to the
waukesha tragedy caused by an suv
those dam suvs those psychopathic suvs
those hate-filled malevolent suvs cnn
says quote waukesha will hold a moment
of silence today marking one week since
a car
drove through a city christmas parade
killing six people and injuring scores
of others a car drove unless we're
talking about a tesla cars don't drive
people drive cars
so the car the car what did the car
drive maybe it was a tesla driving an
suv maybe that's what happened wikipedia
had an entry for the quote 2021 waukesha
christmas parade car crash oops just a
car crash like someone ran a red light
they had another article for a 2021
waukesha christmas parade incident it
was just an incident no it was an attack
it was an attack by a reported black
nationalist a radical leftist a blm
supporter who
hated white people who hated jews which
we'll get into we've got now his social
media history he had a political
motivation and he attacked civilians
and it would appear that there might
have been some relationship between
those two things he was a violent thug
criminal he was not an suv
the new york post has a report out on
the waukesha killer turns out he really
didn't like white people lots of pro-blm
posts a lot of pro black lives matter he
was a mostly peaceful mass murderer uh
he here's just some of the some of the
posts quote so when we start that good
by the way good luck translating this
into english but i'm just reading
verbatim
so when we start back
knocking white people tf out iron wanna
hear it
the old white people
too
knock dem tf out period
okay i think i vaguely can interpret
that next one hitler knew who the real
jews were the negroes are the true
hebrews so this is
a line that has been pushed by various
black nationalist groups including the
hebrew israelites or i think nation of
islam pushes the same kind of thing
this is the group you'll you'll remember
or maybe you won't if you were only
reading the establishment media when
nicholas sandman the smiling kid in the
maga hat at the lincoln monument
when he was being accosted by that
lunatic native american guy there was a
group of black nationalists screaming
slurs at him they were part of the
hebrew israelites if you've ever lived
in new york or washington dc you've
probably run into these guys at a
certain point they believe that the jews
are evil and they're like the fake jews
and the black people are the real jews
and he i guess this guy was was part of
that
this guy said that world war iii would
start when people learn hitler was right
and did the world a favor by killing
jews
and you are not going to hear this
from establishment media outlets you're
going to hear it on my show
and
i guess in the new york post maybe from
a handful of other places maybe
you're not going to hear it from cnn or
nbc or abc or any of the others
the reason i bring it up is not not just
because of what a bad guy
this guy is
it's not even just because of what bad
irresponsible media outlets
the new york times in washington post
and abc and nbc and all those guys are
part of the reason i bring it up is
because it shows you that privilege and
oppression
do not work in the way that we are told
that they work
right we are told
that
white people and men and certainly white
men and certainly straight white men oh
my gosh
straight white men are the most
privileged people in the world who get
away with whatever they want to get away
with and face no adversity whatsoever
and they are repressors who get to get
to do whatever they want
we are told that black people and
hispanic people and other kinds of
people and women and homosexuals and any
other group any marginalized group they
have no privilege they are oppressed
and
push to push to the margins right
they're marginalized and they can't
really do anything because of that evil
straight white man
and yet
when a straight white guy acts in
self-defense
against a mother beater and a pedophile
who are trying to murder him in kenosha
wisconsin
he is
lynched by the public opinion mob and
put on trial and very nearly loses his
entire life
when a black guy when a black
career criminal
who is a black nationalist who hates
white people who hates jews
drives a car and kills a dozens it will
injures dozens of people and kills half
a dozen people
you just you don't really hear about it
that's privilege
right
and the straight white guy that's
oppression
and this gets back to a point even
beyond just lamenting how backwards
the perception of our culture really is
it gets back to this point of a
sociologist i mentioned last week rene
gerard
who who believes that scapegoating who
believes that the victim mentality and
mechanism is at the heart of culture but
he makes this point
you never know
when you're the one scapegoating none of
us do
myself included none of it we just are
not aware of it
and you can see it in other people but
you it's very hard to see it yourself
and because the left controls the whole
culture right now
it's easier for us to see it in them
they don't realize
that uh
that they are scapegoating that's
obviously what they're doing because
when you are scapegoating someone you
always think that you're on the side of
truth and justice and the good and
what's right
speaking of racial issues prince william
just got in trouble
prince william got in trouble in a very
hilarious british aristocratic way
prince william uh said over the weekend
that uh
africans having babies is really
threatening the wildlife he said he said
something to the effect of this is the
direct quote
the increasing pressure on africa's
wildlife in the wild species
as a result i know that this accent's
not great but that's fine
as a result of human population presents
a huge challenge for conservationists is
it does the world over
which
which is
basically the same as saying
when the natives have babies there are
fewer impellers for me to go shoot
i do not i want to go hunt the
rhinoceros but all the africans have the
babies and then they
take away the habitat from the
hippopotamus that i want to go shoot and
my safari and this is very very bad you
see yes yes very very good uh this line
of thinking
is quite morally backwards
but one must admire the hutzpah it's
just so british
it's just
so
colonial is just so imperial i uh i want
to be clear i'm because i made some
comments about this and then it it uh
totally
uh you know there were a lot of articles
about this and i was quoted in a lot of
newspapers around the world i have
nothing but the utmost respect for
prince william i really i actually
really like the royal family and at
least the good members of the royal
family not the megan markels and you
know prince harry and all that but i
actually have a great deal of respect
for the royal family i think they add a
lot of stability and dignity to britain
and to the west uh but this this view is
morally totally backwards
if we are going to care about wildlife
we should care about
the humans first okay if we want to be
good stewards of creation we need to we
need to put humans first and then
everything else will fall into order or
is more likely to fall into order if we
put the delta smelt first if we put the
animals first we put the plant life
first and we disregard humans
and we want to cast humans aside we want
to kill humans through abortion we
neglect humans then we're going to live
in a very backwards world all right
that's our show i'll see you tomorrow
i'm michael knowles this is michael noel
show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show